des femmes et des enfants à la recherche
d'un peu de paix une marche à
contrecoeur qui les éloigne de leurs
graines d'une guerre qui s'étire elle
est juste là quelques mètres la
frontière entre la guerre et la paix ici
c'est tout un petit village avec des
services pour les ukrainiens il ya de la
nourriture chaude gratuite qui les
attend on peut aussi aller s'installer
au chaud en attendant des transports
pour aller plus loin en pologne
dans cette aile tong a pensé aux plus
fragiles qu'il y a un peu de distraction
pour les petits
on trouve également des services
médicaux et le docteur québécois julien
augé venus prêter main forte on voyait
beaucoup de l'avenir à des enfants
d'hydrater des personnes âgées qui avait
par exemple des maladies chroniques qui
avaient plus accès à leurs médicaments
il y a aussi ses blessures invisibles
parfois cachés avec fierté soigner dame
je me suis un peu pour quelles raisons
son conjoint m'a demandé un peu en
retrait aurait-il quelque chose pour
l'anxiété puis il m'a fait un nid mais
des combats armés
étaient moins de ça et voulait quelque
chose pour essayer de ne pouvoir dormir
épuisant surtout les deux derniers jours
le québécois repart après deux semaines
étant satisfaits d'avoir été parmi les
premiers il peut-être la différence que
je pouvais faire au moins savait que je
faisais ma part il ya beaucoup de gens
ici qui font chacun leur part je pense
que ça fait la différence au moins pour
ceux qui ont réussi à traverser ces
longs depuis dijon on est parti hier 7
heures du matin et on arrivait à 3
heures du matin à varsovie ce français a
aussi mis tout côté pour aider il est
venu avec des amis récupérer une
dizaines d'ukrainiens dont les parents
de cette femme ça va j'avais dit moment
elle peut elle a pleuré beaucoup ce
matin il par rapport à tout ce qu'il
m'avait vu il parle parce qu'il reste
qu'ils resteraient ne sais pas s'il va
revenir et revoir notre maison
il resterait rien
de rare retrouvailles si près de
l'ukraine la plupart honteux long chemin
devant eux certains ne savent pas encore
où ils pourront finalement leur petite
valise la nuit est tombée mais le voyage
il n'est pas terminée pour ces
ukrainiens qui monte dans l'autobus ils
ont pour quatre heures de route avant de
joindre var se vit depuis la frontière
comme quoi il faut être bien patient ces
jours-ci ici yannick dumont baron radio
canada en pologne près de la frontière
avec l'ukraine